[Music]  that's Tim Tebow breaking down in tears  as he fed his dog Bronco for the last  time the 32 year old former NFL player  posted a touching tribute to his dog on  Wednesday and revealed it was one of the  toughest goodbyes Kongo on Thursday  Tebow shared a photo of himself standing  in front of Broncos grave writing I'm so  thankful and humbled by everyone support  prayers and love I was able to lay  Bronco to rest in a really special place  Tebow's fiance Demi Lee Nell Peters  comped Adan the post writing I wish I  could take your heartache my love my  heart is broken to Bronco was the  sweetest son in the whole wide world  you